[Music]
[Applause]
number one as we bring in the hall of
famer football night america analyst
tony dungy
tony what happened to the steelers as of
late
well i thought it could possibly happen
four or five weeks ago i think they lost
their identity a little bit they're
winning games
uh not winning them in steelers style
and i think it's caught up with them but
you know dan it really
is so reminiscent to me of our team in
indianapolis in 2006.
we were 9-0 off to a great start we're
winning games close but
finding ways to win and then we hit a
stretch in november and december where
we we really struggled
in fact in december we lost the game to
jacksonville 44-17
fell from the number one seed all the
way to number three everybody said the
season was over
six weeks later we're hoisting the super
bowl trophy we were able to get it
corrected
but these guys they're gonna have to
start running the football they're gonna
have to
get some confidence in their offensive
line where they can throw some deep
balls
i think people have caught up to this
five and six yard passing game
and they're going to have to do
something different on offense i think
it starts
with getting that identity hey we're the
steelers we got to be able to run the
ball in december
well that's what stood out more than
anything else the bengals were more
physical
than the steelers were last night and i
never thought that i would see that i
mean this is a bengal defense
i mean we really don't know the bengals
steelers got household names
and it didn't matter last night the
bengals were the far more the aggressor
bengals could not or would not throw the
ball or felt like they didn't have to
they threw for about 80 yards they're
controlling the game controlling the
line of scrimmage and then
defensively the same way they just hey
we're going to rush the passer
we're going to sit down and play tight
coverage we don't think you're going to
run
we don't think you're going to throw
deep so it's can you get these balls off
before our pressure gets there
and can your guys get open in a five or
six yard space and it was too difficult
okay but what's mike tomlin do like is
there something
it's not magical like what do you do you
got two games left against the colts and
the browns and then you go into the
playoffs
well you can get it back well i'll tell
you what i did in 2006 i said we aren't
making any changes we aren't bringing in
any new people there's no saviors what
we're going to do is get back to basics
we're going to cut down on our defenses
we're going to cut down on our offensive
plays
but we were able to practice back then
you could put pads on
and you could practice tackling you
could practice blocking i'm not sure
they can do that now
and that's part of the problem ben says
he's coming back next year is that good
for the steelers
i think it depends on the way this
season ends up
if he plays like they played at the
beginning and ben can be very very good
at the beginning of the year they're
balanced and james connor is running the
ball and they're
hitting deep shots to chase claypool and
everybody's saying ben's back
well somehow that's been gone they've
lost the confidence that they can run
the ball
and for some reason i think maybe it's
because of the pass protection it was
not very good last night off both
edges and maybe he's feeling like i
can't sit in the pocket and wait on
these
deep balls so they've just become very
limited on offense right now
but also if you're looking at this
defense you lose bud dupree
you lose bush i mean these are two
really really good players
so you can't win games with just your
defense
you are not the same defense and i know
mike thomas is not going to make
excuses i wouldn't make excuses as a
coach but you take out
basically four of your best playmakers
at linebacker
you take out bush who was a tremendous
player and then his replacement
uh um guys helped me with the spelaine
comes in and we don't even know him and
he plays good ball and now he's out
and they've got a backup safety man
playing there and he gets hurt last
night
bud dupree your second best pass rusher
you had that double
edged effect and now you don't have it
coming off the other side so they're
missing some elements that make the
steelers defense
i can understand their defense their
offense has to
step it up and say you know what we are
missing those guys we've got to score
more we've got to control the ball we've
got to run it and control the clock and
that's not
what they're doing right now he's tony
dungy the hall of famer course analyst
for football night america all right
let's look at
all of these teams in the afc because
the afc is stacked once we get to the
playoffs
you know everybody's got a flaw here but
let me start with kansas city i
mentioned a stat that
they really allow you to stay in games
here and and that's going to come back
and haunt them i look at these last wins
tony their last six two points four
three
six six three come playoff time
they may not get that lucky dan i am
worried about
the chiefs i really am i think they're
bored i think they're playing with fire
i think they feel like they can do
whatever they want to do you look at
that game sunday
and you're never going to see drew brees
play as badly as he played
they had the ball for 40 minutes they
out
gained them by 200 yards new orleans has
a ton of penalties that keep things
going
um just their best pass rusher gets
kicked out of the game all these things
and then it's a three-point game at the
end and they've got to make a play to
to win the game le'veon bell's got to
make a run to run the clock out
that game should have been a three score
game
and we've seen it over and over and over
again and they always on that last drive
when they need it they turn it on they
make a play
but in the playoffs one game knockout
all of a sudden that ball gets tipped on
third down
or you know something happens
i just think they're playing with fire
and then you start to look at these
other teams the team that would have the
best chance to knock off kansas city
because you're gonna have to go to
kansas city to knock them off so
who would have the best chance in your
opinion in the afc
well forget about defense because the
saints played the best you can play they
harass
mahomes and they got 32 points so if
you're gonna knock them off
you have to score points so who can go
in there play a semblance of defense
rush the passer with four guys but move
the ball
and score points tennessee can move the
ball and score points and that ground
game could be effective
i don't know if they have the defensive
personnel to really hold them down
maybe buffalo has the best chance that
that you know they're scoring
and josh allen's playing great maybe
they can match them with big plays
and just get enough of a pass rush uh to
do it
but kansas city went into buffalo and
and dominated that game running the
football
early in the year so i'm not sure it's
will kansas city play up to their
standard if they play up to their
standard
for two games i don't think anyone can
beat them
yeah i was wondering about the titans uh
you know because you got derek henry
and you know can he keep his defense off
the field
long enough so they're fresh every time
they go on there against patrick mahomes
i like the colts i think the colts are a
really balanced team
i just don't know about philip rivers in
a big moment tony
well the colts would have a chance to
because they can move the ball
they've got a good offensive line they
they could protect rivers enough they
can hit some deep shots
kansas city is going to give you a
chance on some deep balls because
they're going to play bump and run
they're going to blitz you
ty hilton pascal those guys have a
chance to to make some big plays
they can rush the passer if justin
houston and
deforest buckner could pressure without
blitzing now you make a couple of plays
um you could hang in there in a high
scoring game they would have an
opportunity i think
let's look at the nfc feels like
everybody's flawed here
green bay might looks like they're going
to have home field advantage here but
a run defense concerns me here tone i
don't i don't
run defense is going to get tested this
week yes it is
they're going to get a good idea of how
good they are against
derek henry will really be interesting
because it's strength against weakness
uh the titans do not really have a great
secondary they don't rush the passer
well that is
you know terminal against aaron rodgers
but their achilles heel green bay
is run defense and derrick henry is
going to pound it up inside
and keep those pass rushes at bay i
think we could see a real entertaining
high scoring game
but green bay in that weather they get
the cold weather
uh what team can go up there really
tampa bay are they going to go up there
and light it up
uh in cold weather i doubt it
but even like seattle i could see them
with russell wilson and you know
traveling and pulling off an upset there
um i don't know about the rams i
i am you know every time i think i
understand the rams
you know they surprised me here i was
touting them as the best team in
football three weeks ago i thought their
defense was coming around they can
pressure
the pass or they played physical and
then that run game just kept
uh really jared golf in good situations
where he was throwing outside the pocket
to open receivers
but when you take that run away and you
make them really push the ball down the
field
they struggle and and then you know
that the jets game just did not look
good on
any front so if you're capable of
playing a game like that when you're
fighting for
home field advantage that that was
disappointing
how many stockings do you have behind
you tone
that is uh actually
uh that should be 12. two lauren and i
and all the kids
yeah you didn't even know
you have 12 stockings back there so you
and your wife
and then 12 days of christmas yeah and
10 kids oh my gosh
do you ever forget anybody's name i do i
was
thinking about that dad asked me
everybody
can i get them all and i could get them
all
don't know if i could get them in order
but i could get them all
uh the uh kevin green
passing away at the age of 58 you know
that seems like the last generation of
those that just played football and they
weren't worried about their health
i don't know you know what kevin died of
but at age 58 and he was one of the
great pass rushers
there was almost a uh a wwe
feel he was a wrestler out there he
embraced it the hair he didn't mind
being a bad guy he was entertaining
uh what comes to mind when i say kevin
green
oh just a warrior and that one really
hurts dan we
all went in the 2016 class and when you
go in as a hall of fame class you become
close you're like brothers and
you stay in touch with each other and to
to have one of our classmates pass away
it really really it hit hit hard yeah
uh good to talk to you and uh merry
christmas
hopefully it's uh great what how young
is your youngest
five oh okay
so we're still opening christmas
presents and going through that yeah
our oldest daughter's 35 now so we we've
got a nice 30-year spread
oh my god unbelievable there's a special
place in heaven for you tone
i would say well i'll tell you what keep
the seat warm for me but i don't know if
i'll join you but you know
well we'll talk about that we'll talk
about how to get you out there thank you
i love the
i love the outfits i love the set tell
those guys they did a great job with the
set
thank you buddy uh merry christmas thank
you again all right
thank you thanks dpp great to talk to
you tony dungy hall of famer
hall of fame dad as well